like everything matters equally or close
to equal in phoenix i don't win the
championship without my pit crew
um so everybody matters and every every
person every job in that shop matters
you know the car matters the driver
driver matters picture matters i mean
heck the the business people upstairs
matter you know just as much as anybody
else does because your car's not funded
it's you're not gonna they're not gonna
have the resources to go fast
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is my very very good
friend kyle larson uh we raced together
for years in 2021 he won the
championship uh it finished up at
phoenix i was there that was awesome he
won 11 cup races a ton of dirt races you
want to think he said 33 or 34 races in
2021.
he
had a scenario in the spring of 2020
where he used a racial slur he lost his
job
he had to sell the house that he was
building on the lake in um in north
carolina his life totally changed but he
made the most of it um he won a ton of
races and um earned his way back into
the cup series and had just a phenomenal
year in 2021 we talked about his family
and just how his family dealt with that
and how they've come closer together
throughout all of this those of you out
there that love racing like we talked
about some some nitty gritty you know
what's preparation look like for
the season what does it look like
to prepare for the next season we talked
about what matters more the car the
driver the engine the pit crew all those
kinds of things but we let off with dirt
racing and that's really where we let
off with because he just is so
passionate about it i mean i just know
kyle really well and i know how much he
loves it so i wanted him to defend it
because i don't get it because it's
dirty and it's dangerous so um so i i
wanted to hear his perspectives on all
that and then we finished up with some
manifesting and so kyle is uh kyle is um
a really sweet guy and if you love this
episode and you love what you hear on
the pretty intense podcast don't forget
to click on the subscribe button so that
you can get notifications to hear more
why are you not in
oklahoma
uh we'll go there sunday
because practice is monday
oh i thought it was next week
it's next week
and then a break and then the chili bowl
oh i was like
has hell frozen over are you not going
to the chili ball
maybe someday
but uh no i'm going yeah we'll go we're
going to go saturday to indy for uh
lauren stewart's birthday her 30th
birthday and then
also from there sunday
i see i see
dirt racing your first love
i guess
it is i mean come on that i i mean we
know this to be true
yeah
yeah i feel like uh i feel like i can
talk about a little bit more now so
that's good why
i don't know i feel like
they're
when i first got into my other racing
um
i was maybe frowned upon a little bit
talking about my love for dirt racing
but i love all racing so it's nice that
i can at least talk about my dirt racing
even more now yeah but i think that
maybe i don't know
i'm guessing but after your season last
year and being able to
you know and and doing so many dirt
races as well and doing a whole season
pretty much of dirt racing the year
before
do you feel like it gives your dirt
racing a little bit more of a leg to
stand on because you're like hey um
look what i did
uh i think a little bit of that for sure
i think
yes me being able to race a lot more
kind of and having success uh in all of
it um
because before you know i would have
success in the dirt stuff and maybe not
the nascar stuff so it was i feel like
you could view my dirt racing as a
distraction
but after the the season we had last
year i don't think you can view it as a
distraction at all if anything it's the
opposite i think you know a lot of
people as well as myself and my team
viewed as it helping me so
with that and getting erased a lot more
brought a lot of attention to
all of my racing but the dirt stuff and
and i feel like the the crossover
between fans and series and stuff really
kind of helped grow the sport the last
couple years
yeah and caitlyn sold a shitload of
t-shirts in the last year and a half
yes she has we have two two t-shirt
trailers now so um
yeah
just with we have two because
so i've gotten into the dirt late model
stuff
and like dirt layer model fans don't
really care about buying sprint car
merchandise and sprint car fans don't
care about buying late model merchandise
and then like i'll be racing
you know sprint car one night and late
model the next night so it's hard to
switch out everything and so i've got
i've got two trailers that can go
different places
double down
yeah but she's kind of she's you know
it's it's stressed her out a lot so
um we have a we have another girl
helping us now um and she does a really
good job with that so it's kind of taken
a lot of the load off of caitlyn and and
she's kind of she'll help when she wants
to help and
approve designs and and put her input on
things but as far as
loading and unloading and all that she's
she's got less of a role in that part
now if you were able to let's say
make the same money
and race dirt cars would you do it
um
i don't know i i think
i think maybe
if you'd asked me that question seven or
eight years ago i probably would say
yeah
but i think as i've gotten older um i
just enjoy race in all types of cars so
it doesn't matter to me
if it's dirt pavement stock car sprint
car late model
you know indy car someday who cares like
it doesn't matter to me i just want to i
love i love driving race cars more than
i love making money so
um it doesn't
it doesn't uh it doesn't
i don't know it doesn't it doesn't
matter to me maybe like it it would have
and maybe i
had you know eight years ago or more you
know a chip on my shoulder where like
i'm gonna you know
lean more towards the dirt stuff just to
have their back and stuff but
now like it doesn't matter to me it's
kind of like a cult
yes i mean
i don't know it's gotten it's gotten
less of that way i feel like over the
last few years um because i feel like
there's more transition now because
you've got other drivers besides myself
doing it all
or not all but you know dabbling like
chase is dabbling in the in the dirt
stuff kyle bush with his son braxton
and then yokai ran the shootout last
week so i feel like there's a lot more
of the crossover and i feel like fans
kind of appreciate all racing
as a whole more than maybe they did a
few years ago
i think probably my biggest criticism on
dirt racing again because we're such
good friends and obviously we've talked
about this many times is the danger
aspect you know seeing people you like
people that we know like i know a lot
less people in dirt racing than you do
but like i knew guys that died regular
you know people were passing all the
time and it's um
you know it always just seems like you
know i get it if you're if it's your
livelihood but um when you have a
livelihood that is really good then it's
kind of like dude these guys would give
up they
they give up their job for your job
um so
does that even play into it or is that
part of the allure
i don't think it's part of the allure at
all but um
i don't know i i don't think about it at
all when i strap into a dirt car i'm not
thinking about this could be my last
race i ever run in my life or
what you know i just love i think my
passion for racing and passion for the
racing um
keeps me coming back and like i said i
it doesn't it's not about the money to
me
um but i do know there's a lot of people
that rely on me driving say a nascar you
know cup car there's hundreds of
employees at hendrick there's hundreds
of employees that i was like and ask you
that rely on me so i understand that
side of it but
i i do think the
positives of you know what could come
from you benefiting as a race car driver
could you know outweigh you the risk
side of it but yes there's always the
risk
and i think
anybody could have their own opinion on
that so
for me i feel like it really benefits my
racing and i and i think it's i've been
able to prove it now the last couple
years knock on wood nothing you know bad
has happened but uh
yes i think we all understand that the
risk is there and it's kind of part of
just
it
but
blow by you blow by everybody so i don't
know when you were around though it was
that was like a bad that was a bad few
years um you know tony getting hurt
brian claussen lefler
so many other
not so many other
yes jason johnson i mean and even people
not losing their lives you know breaking
their backs and stuff like that so
um
yes it's dangerous but there's danger in
all everything we do every day you know
even your crossfit can be dangerous
danica i don't do crossfit anymore
i still have a barbell in my garage but
i don't do crossfit anymore
um i mean it's a fact i just i'm just so
curious about it you know so what is it
then that what is like what's the
sensation if you could uh express sort
of
try and paint that picture for people
they see stock car racing but maybe
people don't know as much about dirt
racing and stock cars obviously on
pavement mostly ovals like you know
there's a lot going on that you don't
really see um in a race car so
um you know
but it people can visualize a stock car
going around a track what are you
feeling like a dirt dirt
dirt racing like sideways explain it to
people and then what's the sensation
that's different than a stock car
well i guess i'll start by like
comparing the two cars um
you a stock car is well up until this
year was 550 horsepower
3400 pound race car a sprint car wing
sprint car is 1400 pounds with 950 to
1000 horsepower these days so um
it's the power to weight ratio is is
unreal
um you know pulls the front tires off
the ground you know lights the top rear
tires up on the throttle so there's so
much finesse and uh the style of racing
is is aggressive because the races are
short you know main event might only be
30 laps compared to
four or 500 mile races so um the
intensity is is really high um
and yeah it's just the track conditions
are changing lap by lap uh because you
know it's on dirt so it's you constantly
drying out or getting ruts or building a
cushion and the awareness that you have
to have as a driver is is uh something
that i think is a good tool for when i
go to the nascar side of things where
you have more time to get you know
figure things out um you know adjusting
to a line and stuff like that
the spread car stuff is more intense but
you know the payment stuff i think is
also a good tool because it teaches you
the patience um you know the precision
of hitting your marks that i think
really helps when i get back to the dirt
stuff especially when it comes to like
having to slow down and run the bottom
so
um
i don't know just the the
they're hard to compare
there is really not much comparison
but uh they're both really fun
what's the sensation that you love do
you love being sideways do you love like
running by the wall every night pretty
well not every night but i'm sure last
night
uh i don't know i think i think the
sensation uh even though the tracks too
the tracks and dirt are way smaller
you're racing on a quarter mile to a
half mile where the smallest track in
nascar is a half mile so
um
uh you know it's uh
just that speed that you feel on a
quarter mile could feel faster than what
michigan on a two mile track would feel
like even though you're going
almost half the speed uh sometimes so
just because the quickness and the
reaction that it takes to in the
suspension you know as a stock car like
it's pretty rigid it doesn't move a
whole lot you know if you hit a bump it
doesn't move a ton where a sprint car i
mean your your car will travel inches
um in bouncing and flipping and wrecking
and all that so uh but i would say the
sensation of the speed and
my heart rate gets way higher uh in a
dirt race than than it would in a stock
car it's just because i think in the
stock cars you have such a long straight
away to kind of relax and things get
spread out so
yeah it's uh the sensation of
reaction and speed is wild
people which i would i feel like would
maybe be similar to like an indy car i
would have to imagine you know because
they're quick and
twitchy and edgy oh yeah this is the i
mean i mean when i jumped back in an
indy car a couple years ago for the last
time um i mean i took off out of pit
lane and first thought was like oh [ __ ]
i forgot how fast these are like i
accelerated off of pit lane on the back
straightaway at indianapolis and i was
like oh god and then i was like i can't
even turn the wheel i was like this is
so hard
yeah um
i mean there's a lot about an indie car
that i think is probably similar to a
dirt car did your cars have power
steering
yes yeah they have power steering which
is thankfully they do but it still gets
you can get heavy you a heavy wheel when
you're bouncing through holes and stuff
like it'll it'll try and yank itself out
of your hands the dirt late model
those cars are similar horsepower to a
sprint car but they weigh i think a
thousand pounds more
and there's so much load on the front
tires in those things just the way the
suspension is
on the right front it makes the steering
really heavy in those so yeah i've have
it where not i have had it where like i
go through a hole and it'll
literally yank out of my hands and i
take off up the track so
um definitely takes more arm strength in
the late model um
but still again the sprint car compared
to that like your heart rate is way
higher in in the sprint car compared to
late model
did you win chili bowl last year
yeah the last two years i've won
for those listening that um might not
know
as much detail
about you
um
your season in 2021 was just ridiculous
i mean
you won 11 cup races 10 regular season
and the all-star race which pays a
million bucks right was it a million
bucks to win the all-star race
um
you got to try and compete with caitlyn
for those t-shirt sales money so it's
good that you won that um and then i
don't know all the dirt races but
obviously you won the chili bowl and i
know you want a whole bunch of others
which for people that don't know like
these are the biggest dirt races these
are like the these are the super bowl
these are the world series this is the
daytona 500 of of dirt racing and it
almost feels like there's more energy
and excitement around it than even a cup
race on some level like you can you you
would probably agree um so which one
which dirt races did you win that were
the big ones yeah last year i was able
to run
i ran what a [ __ ] a sprint car dirt
late model and a cup car
and i won marquee events on all four
types of cars so yeah i started out with
the chili bowl at uh
in tulsa in the [ __ ] so the two big
races i won the [ __ ] were the chili
bowl and the bc39 that's in the infield
at ims
uh in the sprint car i won the kings
royal and the knoxville nationals those
are the two biggest sprint car races of
the year yeah
in the dirt late model i won
uh the prairie dirt classic which is i
would say probably like the fourth
biggest race in dirt late models and
then
i mean the koch 600 the all-star race
phoenix
there was there was a lot a lot of good
good big ones uh in cup as well so
that's definitely something i'm really
proud about um i think i ran 96 or seven
races uh last year and won 33 of them so
definitely really good year so really
good last two years um for sure well
because you won everything the year
before in 2020 when you went dirt racing
too
yeah we won
i think i was 40 i was like right at 50
i won 46 races in 2020.
i mean the dirt racing's just crazy you
can rack so many races up because it's
just one night like when you go to a
stock car race or an indy car race or
something like that it's a three-day
weekend you can only it's one a weekend
um
so i mean indycar does 20 20-ish races a
year stock cars do
38.
basically 30
36 regular season and two bonus races
with the all-star and then the um
uh
what is it the bud shoot what is it what
they call that now the clash the first
very first one before the daytona 500 so
38 races but but dirt racing man it's
like three or four a
week yeah like 90 on the sprint car
schedule right it's 90 races yeah the
outlaws is
outlaws is like 88 or 90 something yeah
it's like a baseball and i race you know
i'll race like not just the outlaw stuff
you know i race all-star outlaw i don't
run i can't run for points so i can go
hit way more shows than even a points
chaser can so yeah like june and july i
mean i'm i might not come home at all
i'll be you know on the road or fly into
other dirt races fly into the nascar
races so that's why you're skinnier than
me now and that's why you weigh like 128
pounds dripping wet you know
yep gotta stay that that's my way of
working out is raising a lot dude it's a
lot
okay so how does the fam deal with this
because
i mean caitlyn obviously running the
t-shirt trailer last year in 2020 and
then i'm sure a ton still in 2021 when
you went and did what you did
you know outside of the cup races but
i mean that's just a shitload of races
and like shoot me i mean you know it i
didn't love the dirt racing it wasn't my
favorite my dad loves it my my mom
i didn't really care
wasn't my jam um so how how how has that
gone does caitlyn go to all of them
still and then you have owen how old is
owen
he just turned seven a couple weeks ago
seven and audrey is
she'll be today yeah actually for me so
yeah i mean it's it's tough i mean it's
it's tougher obviously on them than than
myself i feel like but really it's your
choice yeah uh but 2020 2020 you know
with everything that happened and then
that was
honestly a
very
it was a fun year because i spent we
spent seven weeks
on the road in our motorhome driving
from track to track selling t-shirts
like those are memories that
we made and we'll never forget
um because it was coveted so the kids
weren't in school which was nice this
year was was a little more difficult
because owen and audrey both were in
school um
and so they didn't go to many nascar
races because they well really up until
i feel like the first half of the year
they couldn't really go with the coveted
protocols and then even at the end like
it's just one day shows so we would just
fly in and fly out so there was no need
to take the motorhome no need for them
to go
but they would go to a lot of my dirt
races and
it definitely gets tough during the
school year so
actually
they just went back to school yesterday
and they're gonna go to school for this
week um you know because it was winter
break so they just going back and then
we're actually gonna
we hired a teacher and we're gonna do
homeschooling now so
um that'll that'll make things a little
bit easier to travel and have a little
bit more freedom and have the family
there with me and um try to try to find
some sort of balance
i love that i think that especially with
the way everything's going in with all
the coveted stuff like i i don't have
kids um but my sister has three and two
of them are in school
and just to know that you know it's
always you know some schools are math
some are not some have certain rules
some don't kid exposure you know blah
blah blah blah blah and it's like you
know i and this is just my opinion but
at that age you know at seven and four
it's like
i mean learn the basics but you know
you're not getting your law degree or
your doctorate in something
at seven years old so like go climb
trees have some fun
and
you know it's cool that you have a
teacher that will then be able to kind
of still keep them going but um i'm far
more on the other side of things with
school like i mean i have a ged so
yeah i think i think it'd be good for us
too and owen he kind of struggles in
school a little bit and and he has
tutors and stuff there and um he really
likes the tutoring because it's more
one-on-one time and he can like focus so
i think you know having the
homeschooling and having a teacher fully
dedicated to him is gonna
be great and i think he's gonna improve
quickly so
uh i'm excited about it we yeah you know
where my house and my shop are so we're
going to build the classroom at the shop
and then
yeah so it's going to be it's going to
be cool because you know we will like
walk through the woods to get to the
shop and
um
you know maybe once someone gets
comfortable we can just send him on his
own to the shop which would be nice
that's really cool the one thing about i
mean nascar versus you know other racing
series or even other sports is
um this off season's just so short i
don't really have an off season normally
sure and normally you go to new zealand
for dirt racing for christmas time
but you didn't go this year for the
first time in a while right
yeah not the last two years because of
covid so yeah like you said the
off-season for a normal nascar driver is
short and then for myself like
i don't ever have an off season so this
this year has been really weird to me i
haven't raced since thanksgiving which
is not gonna stop
you're gonna suck kyle you're not gonna
know what to do i know i feel like i'm i
feel like i'm getting behind but so it's
been weird it's it's been weird to have
christmas at home and
be at home and not race and um our house
is as clean as it's ever been
no well it's been a team teamwork
caitlyn and i both we've been you know
shuffling rooms around and kind of
remodeling rooms and just cleaning and
um
it's because we're home we're never
we're never home for more than a few
days at the time so that part of it's
been nice but i can't wait to get back
grayson um count down the days to head
to tulsa and get back in a race car
because it's been
well i mean
because when everything happened in
what month was that in 2020
um
april march april so the spring of 2020
obviously having the issue with you know
the racial slur and then
you know losing your job and then but at
the same time
you were
building a beautiful house on the lake
in north carolina so you sell your house
so like it makes sense that you would be
doing renovations in that house that
you're in now because you kept it but
like i mean you talked about how
um
you talked about how the the trip last
like 2020s like road trip for months and
being on the road with the kids and
everything was really cool it had to
have been super super emotional and hard
and what was that what was the hardest
part because i know that was the a good
part and that's so cool to look at the
positive um and i'm sure there's even
more than that but what what was it what
what were you thinking at that time like
where did your darkest thoughts go so
yeah i mean when it all kind of first
happened and and i mean you instantly
know you made a huge mistake and
um then as the days are
you know there's so many
phone calls and conversations and stuff
and
uh really
you know dark emotional times the first
you know handful of days is because you
realize you're losing your job and
that's everything you've worked really
hard for your parents have you know put
in so much of their own time and effort
and
you know you've let them down as well so
many other people and
and just confusion i guess at that point
too because you don't know where your
career is headed you don't know
what you're gonna be able to do um you
don't know i i knew i could always fall
back on dirt racing um
and that's what i did but even even
there
it's like yeah that's yes that's
something i always had dreamt of doing
was being back a full-time racer but
not at 27 or eight years old whatever it
was when it all first happened um yeah i
thought that was something i do in my
40s so it was just like kind of
confusing and and
that didn't really know
how to feel about it i was happy you
know i was doing something that i still
loved and racing and all that but
um just i don't know you i feel like
when you have a job in your nascar like
you have a plan you know what your life
is you know what your life's gonna be
like for however long you want it to be
like that and then you know
like a light switch it all changes and
it's like shoot now
what am i going to do what are we what
am i going to do to make money what you
know schooling for my kids you know how
are people going to treat my kids stuff
like that it was just
a lot of rollercoaster emotions then
you're winning races which makes you
feel happy but
you're still not doing exactly what you
wanted to do at that time
so it was it was definitely difficult
and i didn't really see much hope of
getting back to nascar for months even
with me went in a ton of races last year
and
um and i finally got to a point where i
was like okay this is this is fine this
is what i'm gonna do for the rest of my
life and i'm gonna love it my we're
gonna figure it out we're gonna
you know travel a lot and and
you know live in the motorhome or
whatever it may be but um in about that
time is when things started finally
coming around to where i could see maybe
a path of getting back to nascar and um
it all it all worked out way better than
i ever thought it would and um just very
thankful and lucky and and blessed and
then to to have the season that we had
this year to kind of repay
all the people who
you know supported me through the dark
times um you felt great who and who were
like who were who were the most
important people during that time
well my family and friends number one i
think uh jp who you know
my manager jp
rod mosquitz um
i mean there were so many people and
then rick hendrick especially for
for taking a chance on me and and
knowing kind of who i was as a person
and knowing where i was going to grow
even more as a person so um jeff gordon
i mean there there is it's hard it's
impossible to name everybody but because
we know you like we know you and we know
that we know your character
you know you're from california you're
asian you're like there's all kinds of
things like it's just like you're not
that guy so i i would imagine of course
that's why there were so many people
that supported you but i'm curious who
gave you the best advice was there
something that stuck was there something
out there that you were like somebody
said this and i was like
[ __ ] you're right or i needed to hear
that
uh i don't know i had like
tons of conversations um
you know with with other
african-americans and stuff and just
learning their experiences
um of you know stuff that they don't
openly talk about in the public
um
and just like opening my eyes to their
experiences really
was a great thing for me to kind of
listen to what they go have gone through
so um i mean
i talked to so many people i had a
diversity coach doug harris he was great
he was kind of you know like a a really
good person for me to just learn a lot
about learn about his experiences and
what he's gone through but also he
you're teaching me um other things so
yeah i would say doug harris is probably
the number one guy that i could kind of
lean on um
you wouldn't all go first happened in
those first few months um you know i i
can't think of like one bit of advice
but uh learning his and others
experiences was like i said extremely
eye-opening to me what did you hear that
was so eye-opening he had gosh how many
kids did he have like
six or seven
children and if they were to get pulled
over and
how are they gonna handle that how is
that gonna you know result you know were
we
that him thinking about his children
like
i don't think about you know if owen had
his driver's license i'm not going to
think about him getting pulled over and
what you know the risk of the result
might be so
yeah it's just yeah and that's not
something i ever thought about like i
never thought about people you know
parents wake up on the daily worried
about their kids so
um and you're worried about in that type
of thing so just stuff like that was
like wow i didn't i didn't i never
thought about that so just learning
experiences and stuff like that was was
crazy
yeah yeah i'm sure but what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger
and your character came through
um
so
is there anything that in your life
you're like okay this is like gonna
change forever like this is this is that
thing that i'm not gonna do anymore i'm
gonna always do this or you know is
there something moving forward where
you're like this is how my life really
changed
um i think just having more
awareness for what people go through and
and the things that you say and how it
might affect them and as you know i'm
not the greatest with words so
oh my gosh can we just pause for a
minute and talk about the words okay
l has called me bulky
um that was fun one day when you're like
you're just you're just really bulky and
i'm like and i meant like strong like it
was right
right and then another time we were
having delicious breakfast at this very
very fancy hotel restaurant in
california napa valley got brought up
the other day
and you had your breakfast and first you
weren't sure what to do with your eggs
and we're like first i don't eat
breakfast that's why
but you didn't know what to put on your
eggs so we're like salt and pepper
and then you ate it and and it was like
wow how was that kyle and you're like it
was it was the beef hash i think it was
called it was and you said it was too
flavorful
so
yeah kyle can you can be a little like
um
what goes on in your head and what comes
out of your mouth aren't really jiving
yeah i get i i blame my mom for that
she's she's worse than i am so really no
i think this oh yeah yeah if you would
oh my gosh yeah you need to spend some
time around my mom and you would
understand
why my brain and my mouth don't work
together that's why she's always just
video video video taping
that's probably a reason why she's
always behind the camera
for sure
yeah okay so so so anyway those are some
examples of kyle being you know and loki
is a compliment i think it i think you
understood but it took i have a feeling
that in the comments people will be like
um bulky is if you're a girl like i
don't even know would you want me to
call you bulky
yeah but i know i'm not bulky so
i meant strong like you're i remember
where were we driving to like charleston
or something and we
stopped
like somewhere at a gas station or
something and i don't know why
i gave you that compliment what i
thought was a compliment but
over as a compliment yeah maybe we were
in charleston or something like that
yeah and that's probably why when we
drove home from charleston on that trip
of
eating our way through through south
carolina why we stopped remember we went
into juicy friends after we went and we
just like tried to pile up on whatever
they had because you probably gave me
like a a
a complex then that i was bulky oh my
god i was thinner than i am now for sure
i'm like i wasn't bulky
i was i was i was um i meant it as a
compliment
muscular at worst
yeah i mean okay whatever let's move on
before before i put my foot in my mouth
again you had a super kick-ass season in
2021 i was so stoked to be there at the
end and
but i'm curious
uh
your strength and getting my my dinner
to what i wanted it the night before
oh yeah you're maybe without that meal i
wouldn't have i wouldn't want
yes we went to dinner and they didn't
have you wanted um
yeah yeah chicken parmesan and
they were out and i was like do you have
chicken and they're like yeah and then
they're like it's just not breaded i'm
like it's easy just dip it in egg put
the breading on it and then she went
back and made [ __ ] happen and you got
your chicken parm yeah cause me
non-confrontational kyle i'm like okay
it's fine i'll just order something else
and danica is like no he wants a chicken
farm he's gonna get a chicken parm it's
easy it was the night before the biggest
race of the year to win the championship
can we tell another story about danica
trying to get what she wanted done about
fourth of july many years ago
when
your cat climbed up a tree because my
dog chased your cat
and i felt really bad about that and um
so you went down to go see if the local
um fire department would be able to get
my house is like right across the street
from the fire station so it's yeah
very close and they were all they said
they couldn't
and i was like oh
oh really
and then i went and you came with me and
you stood
way back and i tried to be nice at first
for like a minute for like a minute i
was nice and then they it was dark and i
was like i was hoping you could help me
my friends came and like cats stuck in
the tree and and they were getting ready
they were doing nothing there was like
four or five of them doing nothing and i
was like
you know i really would appreciate it
and they were just putting up the wall
they're like in the movies it makes it
seem like we're supposed to do this but
we don't and they'll just come down
eventually i'm like yeah when they're
dehydrated and die
and it's summer it's like july in north
carolina
and i mean i threw some serious shade
out there to get them to come i threw i
i threw out social media disgrace to
them i was like look if you guys don't
come
and they came
i did not say a word i was like oh my
god if i could just if i could just
leave right now i would because i felt
so
embarrassed so bad for everybody i felt
bad for them i felt bad for the cat i
felt yeah
it was going to be better than that i'm
trying to do better i'm trying to let
things go more
i'm a little more zen than i used to i
was gonna say you're more zen like now
so
how like one of the things transitioning
from one year to the next is you never
really know how it's going to go
right like you want to have the same
year again next year
if you do
i mean
i'd be freaking blown away because it
was just ridiculous
for people who don't know i mean the
normal amount of races that the cup
champion wins in a year is probably what
four to six i was gonna say five to
seven maybe at the most you won twice
twice as many on top of all the big dirt
wins so
having the same year again would be
would be amazing and kind of it would be
phenomenal so but the one thing that
happens is when we all get to daytona at
the beginning of the year you never
really know how it's going to go because
people work on their cars in the off
season rules packages change sometimes
engine packages there's all kinds of
things that can shift and you really
don't know what happens from that you
know november through february time with
all the other cars
so
you know how it's going to go is kind of
a mystery so
what i mean i was never in the shop
enough to know
let's face it um it wasn't my fun zone
um
but what what happened like what can you
do what can you do as a team like what
do you know is happening
whose job is it to make sure the car is
to make sure it's really good the next
year
i mean
so like this year is
this year is different than any other
year for me because
we're going from the gen 6 car which is
what i was always in even though it had
different rules packages yo between ears
and stuff but anyways we're going from
the gen 6 to the next gen car which is
totally different so
yeah like i think you can't have any
expectations i don't like i i mean we we
just won 10 11 races last year we could
go winless this year it's just how it
goes with a new car but
um
so i don't know i haven't had much
testing in it i was gone while they
tested in charlotte so i don't even know
like how they drive that much
so far it's looked like it's a bit of a
disaster
yeah i i mean
i think they've made improvements on it
um
but yes i think they've kind of ran
your times kind of ran out a little bit
to really
do r d on what's the proper package but
as far as the off season stuff yeah i
don't know like i think
i like i'm probably similar to you i
don't
i don't know anything about racecar you
know more about a race car than i do so
i don't go in the shop at all and like
pick their brains out
what they're changing where their
improvements are that they've found and
what's the difference in the cars like i
can't even talk about what the
difference is um
i guess it's independence independent
suspension
uh the shifting is different stuff like
that what does that even mean so yeah i
don't know but uh
yeah um maybe people think it's funny
that we don't really know that stuff
drivers are really up on it some drivers
are into it they get it you know some of
them are really into the cars but i i
never i didn't even know where the sway
bar was and the i don't know i've looked
under a stock car maybe twice in my
career but
i mean it doesn't matter it doesn't i
mean my job is to drive and there's the
work on it and so yeah i think your
cliff my crew chief cliff daniels the
engineers the engineers and crew chiefs
from the other teams um really i think
you have to lean on everybody at your
race shop to
prepare your cars especially when it's a
new generation car um you gotta lean on
chevrolet and even other teams you know
i think the other chevy teams are really
communicating
well right now from what i hear so
um that should hopefully
you know
give us an edge uh or get us closer to
where we need to be once the season
starts if you were to rank
driver car
engine crew chief pick like what
what rank does that stuff fall i don't
want to go simple car versus driver
because
i mean you can you can answer car versus
driver what's more important um but i'm
kind of curious of maybe a little bit of
a deeper sort of look into what matters
in your opinion
yeah um yeah i mean i've only ever
thought about it as
car and driver but i think once you
start throwing in all those other things
um i think then it almost it almost
narrows it's where everything's
closer to equal like everything matters
equally or close to equal
because
you could
view your pit crew like
in phoenix i don't win the championship
without my pit crew
so everybody matters and every every
person every job in that shop matters um
you know the car matters the driver
driver matters picture matters i mean
heck the the business people upstairs
matter you know just as much as anybody
else does because if your car's not
funded it's you're not gonna they're not
gonna have the resources to go fast so
it's really hard i feel like to
say one thing is more important than the
other or has a bigger factor than the
others am i my car versus driver
car versus driver
um
i would have to give the edge to the car
for sure um i think
you can look at my career i i think
you know in 2017
i won four races um 2018 i won zero
races
2021 i won 11. so i you know just
i'm not i'm not i'm probably a better
driver than i was back then but not
way better um i just think you know that
i'm at hendrick motorsports your their
equipment was and resources um you made
the car
better so yes
your car means a lot but you still also
have to have a really good driver i mean
nobody that lucks into a win uh or or
championship for that matter yeah well
it's just simple if you just take like a
great driver and a bad car versus a
great car and a bad driver like i mean
you know if you it you can't
this last year in 2020 and won zero and
21. and he's
he's an amazing race car driver so yeah
you know somewhere
they were off in their on their race
cars
oh i remember i remember all your wins
in 2017 because we flew together to and
from all the races and that jet had to
wait for you and all your wins every
time and i was like here we go again
i appreciate it oh man it's okay
um the jet was going anyway every
driver's different i mean i'm tell the
truth
now about my preparation but
i found it like
i mean sometimes i'd ask for data and i
wouldn't always use it i just wanted
them to think i was that happened every
now and again sometimes i did look at it
sometimes i thought that watching old
in-car videos i used that did that more
in indy car where i watched in-car and i
was like oh okay that kind of helps me
get in the rhythm and feel it in my body
or what it's like but i didn't there
wasn't a lot like it wasn't like and and
even like preparation not only from the
technical stuff but from
you know
physical stuff like
getting sleep and all that stuff it's
like i had great races where i didn't
get much sleep and i had great races
where i got tons of sleep like it just
didn't you know it was bad bar was
probably good that day probably it's
like somebody it's like you have a good
race one and like bad race last week
good race this week and they're like wow
you know what was it i'm like well i
just woke up and i just remembered how
to drive
so what's yours look like what is what
do you find matters the most to your
preparation your performance and it
could be nothing that's a fine answer
no i so
i feel like
you know i like getting as much data as
i can possibly as much as my team can
supply me um
and you know i probably like what like
this is that's a that's just like data's
a big word so i mean i could pull up my
no like just trying to like efi data
with you know everything traces break
steering
anything whether it yes all that stuff
smt videos that they compile uh of the
smt you know other drivers and what
stood out smt
it's uh oh you weren't around for smt
oh wow um so it's it's it's the steering
brake throttle uh speed trace all that
and it's put on this like digital it
looks like a video game like you it like
overlaps your car versus somebody else's
car and uses gps and all that and like
it's pretty cool and
it's way better than dark fish remember
dart fish that's what i was gonna say i
was like i remember dark fish yeah so
it's like dark fish is non-existent
anymore everybody just uses smt because
you can like you can get whatever angle
you want you can break down the corners
and pit stops and all that stuff can you
look at the car itself like the like i
don't
know
you spin in real life your car doesn't
spin on the deal because it's just gps
it's not it doesn't it doesn't factor
yaw and all that but oh so you're not
looking at the actual cars on track
because dart fish would video you so
it's not that no this is this looks like
a video game like it's a it's a fake car
um
so do you practice this before you go or
is this something you get after
um well you get you you can get like
after you've been on track that is yeah
after you've been on track all that
information during practice like when we
have practice you can look at it live
of your people out there
but yes so that's really helpful but i
like looking at anything whether it be
you know pass race history cautions pit
stops two tires four tires like when
that window is fuel windows we look at
with smt is really nice um you can look
at like green flag stops and like how
far around the corner you can go before
you start hitting the brakes and you can
you know link it up with satellite and
like oh wow breaking markers this yes
it's like this billboard you need to get
new to the brakes and downshifting later
and stuff like that that helps and
so yeah i mean i like to just pick apart
everything that we can and usually we
have those are we call our five team
meeting um on thursdays where like the
engineers compile all this information
and data and then we have like a
hour and a half ish you know meeting
whether it be if i'm in person i go to
the shop or we do it on zoom
or microsoft teams and uh
kind of go over all that information
just to get prepped kind of doing your
homework before the weekend
um
so yeah that stuff really helps me a lot
and then like on the physical side of
things when i'm in town i work out
i still work out well it's not chip and
gas racing anymore it's track house but
okay do you get bulky no no still still
not not bulky but i work out with josh
wise and he's he kind of heads the i
think he was doing it when you're around
so but i mean not that you or anybody
you worked out there but he he helps the
chevy drivers a lot so i do that and i
really feel like that kind of helps me
i mean it gets physically probably you
know better but i think what do you do
in the gym what do you do because josh
wise is a cardio king
yeah it's he's like a triathlon kind of
guy right yeah but really i feel like
what we do in there is more like
hand-eye stuff and
it's like pitfalling in indianapolis
sort of probably i don't know i've never
been there but i feel like we more we
more are training our minds than
anything so i really feel like since
i've kind of bought into his program
more than i used to i used to never you
know i just think working out was was
dumb but uh
now i i enjoy doing it because i feel
like it makes me
mentally stronger feel like i'm more
prepared race car driver confident
so i enjoy i enjoy going out in there or
going to work out at his place and
i haven't done much of it this off
season so i probably need to need to get
back in but uh i do enjoy doing that
stuff um
and and yeah i think it's it's
definitely helped me become a better
driver last few years
well what um what kind of
goals for i mean i mean i don't even
know where you go from last year but
are you one of those people that comes
up with goals for freaking new year or
not
no you're gonna like start a diet so you
get even skinnier
i've probably had new year's resolutions
but i've never once stuck through with
them but uh tell me what have some of
them been
oh probably like
eating healthier and stuff like that oh
you love salads i do love salads but
i mean the biggest bowls
yeah i've never had a bad salad
never ever have had a bad salad so i do
like that but
yeah i don't know as far as race goals
go i don't i also don't like setting
goals either um
because in nascar it's hard it's like we
talked about in the offseason you never
know how your next year's gonna go so
i don't like
really setting goals until you get like
a month to a month and a half into the
season and that's like when you realize
like okay this is where we're at as a
team yeah this is what i feel like
reachable
let's try and
do better than that um
so i don't know i don't know what my
goal would be this year i just want to
win races win races and win a
championship would be great but
until that until like i said you get a
month month and a half in you don't
really it's hard for me to set goals
well
what role does spirituality and crystals
play in all of this
my fellow hippie
i mean
you know we used to get laughed at
because we kind of bought into i'm
nowhere close to you do you see my
crystal balls here right there yeah
when's the next full moon
good question i think it's just we just
had a new moon so a couple weeks
did you get them laid out and charged up
i did not um if i remember i do i said
i'm i have these very deep window sills
and i'll set everything on the
windowsill um
on a full moon but i didn't do that
um but but for real but you're kind of
you're kind of into that uh
i mean more so than definitely more so
than caitlyn and ricky were that's for
sure like they would be making fun of
you and i would
not really you know i'm like what's
wrong with it like it's okay but uh have
you ever had a psychic reading
uh when i was a kid
and i and i i would like to go back um
for sure and they're because they're
always they're always
like
right
which is crazy
like i've never met this person in my
life like how do they know what's going
on in my life so yes so like i do like
doing things like that makes me have
some sort of belief in like the
spiritual stuff and
um and all that but
um i don't what about it like what what
about the spiritual stuff do you believe
in what do you buy into that caitlyn's
like no way
well i think
i don't know like because it's tough
like you get into religion and all that
too so um i feel like you have to be
like
touchy with that um you know because
caitlyn has her beliefs and she and her
family does and there and she's really
strong with it and i don't believe like
just one thing like i'm open to
thoughts and and i think that's where
yeah i think just my openness
um you remember me curious
do you remember that night i think i can
see you you're in your kitchen right
aren't you in your kitchen
um do you remember that night at my i
was over at your house we were all there
and i started talking about some jim
carrey thing this is what 2017
and i started talking about jim carrey
talking about like something about
tetrahedrons and
you know it was some video i saw
and then ricky looked at me and he was
like we're gonna get the pastor to talk
to her and straighten her out and i was
like
um what like i looked at him if like my
eyes could kill we were highly judged
for our interest in spirituality
like i said i'm not i'm not as far out
they're not even close to as far out
there as you are i feel like i'm kind of
in the middle of you if we're comparing
you versus like ricky and caitlin i feel
like i'm like somewhere in the middle
um
but
yeah i don't know
i just how do you think the world works
then how do you think the world works
i don't know i i don't i don't i don't
think about it i don't
i'm i'm happy to wake up every day and
and take my kids to school and look
forward to spending time with them and
going racing on the weekends but
so i don't know i don't i don't i've
never like sat down and thought about it
i've obviously heard
you know you
and then you have like caitlyn and
that side and
um like i said i'm just i don't really
know how the world works so i'm open to
many different ideas
how do you hope it how do you hope it
works like how could spirituality be
like
something because there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on in the world and there's a lot
of negativity and there's a lot of fear
and i see my spirituality playing into
the whole dynamic in a way that goes
beyond kind of the
television
programming
um
sort of the way that things appear and
thinking more about the way things
really are and
so what what function do you think that
having a little bit more of a spiritual
mind serves you i don't know i need to
spend more time with you so you can you
can teach me
should we go to sedona
yeah yes yeah we should
um for sure i think i think my first
my first like wow that was weird moment
was uh
so i was 14
um
and i
just turned 15. and
this guy who kind of was like my mentor
at the time racing sprint cars because
that was my first year ever racing
sprint cars he was like hey i want you
to go watch this movie
um it was called the secret
um
and you know i interviewed rhonda bryan
i interviewed rhonda bryan oh really
yeah you should listen to it it's very
fascinating and i'll tell you all the
stuff afterwards that she told me all
right so yeah i was like whatever i'll
watch this movie and uh
i watched it and i was like wow okay
that's cool like yeah i'm really gonna
try and change my thought process and
just thinking positive and how that you
know reacts to my world and
i won my first ever sprint car race like
the next night
um
did you know that i mean i watched that
i'd watch that and i went and won in
japan
really yeah i swear to god like i
watched it and then i went to japan and
won yeah so i've watched that movie a
few different times like whenever i
not in a while i haven't watched it but
whenever i would be like in a slump and
you know having a bad string of races
and stuff like i would watch it and then
i would start you know having better
thoughts and going to run running better
and who knows like if it if it mattered
but i feel like it mattered so
um
yeah like i tell people to watch that
watch that movie or read the book but i
haven't read read the book but watch the
movie anyways i'm kind of more of a
movie girl anyway myself i mean i read a
little bit of books now but i'd rather
watch the movie again i just got no josh
is josh wise he's he i
in my office i've got like 10 or 12
books that he's given me and i haven't
i've read maybe 20 pages of like one
book
i'm more of a movie guy
he just gave me a couple more books for
christmas but like whatever
just like kind of that stuff like your
mindset and i i don't know exactly
because i haven't read them but you know
he's given me you kind of like notes
about and really i think a lot of it
kind of just comes like to your mind and
how your your mind
can yeah i mean affect your
daily life and decisions and how things
how things
happen
i agree okay back to goals for 2020. you
obviously if your mind is this powerful
let's just create some
yeah
i mean i'm sure i'm sure
yes obviously in the back of my mind
like i have
lofty goals but like
come on kyle i mean at least at least
doing what we did like it into existence
at least what we did in 21 but
i mean it's just yeah it's hard to know
i'm not going to say well i won 11 races
last year i'm going to win 15 this year
like that's
hey it could be done i guess but
so what 10 i'm also going to win 10
again i'm a realistic person but uh
i don't know i don't check back a month
and a half into the season and i'll give
you some goals
okay then what's uh like
obviously been in cup for long enough
now um you've won everything in dirt i
don't even know if there's anything left
to win there so what races
if you could pick like your top three
races that you'd want to win in 2012
2022 what would they be yeah that would
be better and why
so i mean obviously the daytona 500
that's our biggest one um
but to me now you know i always wanted
to win the bristol knight race that was
like my that was my race i wanted to win
so bad and i was able to do that last
year
um
next would be the
really i don't know if we go to
darlington twice but a race at
darlington would be in my next one i
finished i finished second at darlington
the last three or four races i ran there
so
yeah so
for those who don't know also kyle tried
to pull
a video game move the last lap of the
race which was so freaking fun to watch
you tried to pass denny which is a good
friend so i'm sure that was a bit of a
situation but tried to pass denny by
going flat pretty much through like i
don't know if you would you probably
weren't trying to go flat through turn
three of darlington were you
no i i i lifted but i just didn't use
any break and then just pinned it
against the wall and then once i was in
the wall then yes i was in the gas but
also i had to come off the gas because i
got to him way quicker than i thought i
would and i didn't want to spin him out
so
um but yes it was
like i mean we've all done it in video
games and
it works and video games are like
i didn't expect it to work just as good
in real life
it's your move now it's your move not
only that but it destroys the car so it
doesn't need to have it doesn't have to
go through tech yeah right
now i'm glad honestly i didn't win that
one because
i don't
think that would have been like the
fairest way to win
yeah i mean that's that's respectable i
mean but that's the guy you are like you
you that is who you are
yeah yeah but no it made for a good
highlight reel it sure did
all right well then since we're just in
a manifesting space here so we've got
daytona 500 night race at bristol and
darlington
what are three off track things that you
hope
come to fruition in 2022
um
well currently owen is retired from
racing um but he loves baseball nowadays
yeah no i've got him already signed up
for baseball camp once we get home from
uh chili bowl but he's talked about
racing again here lately so if he does
race i would love
i guess this is still on track but i
would love for him to win his first race
because you know he he wants it bad
um
and and he's he's i feel like lost a lot
of confident like personal confidence in
racing
um so i want to see him get i want to
see him become a more confident
child i guess more than anything
um i see the confidence in baseball um
but just overall like i guess with
racing i wanted more confident with
schooling more confident
stuff like that um
i don't know um
you know caitlyn and i just continue to
get closer and stronger and and become
even better parents and stuff like that
um
what what other things could i do um
i need one more thing right for this
year off the track
uh
i need to think about that i should have
known that you're going to ask all these
these intense pretty intense questions
i've got your final question okay where
do you want to go then for the uh for an
off week because you get probably two is
it still two off weeks out of the season
yeah they're technically calling it two
because there's a week after the clash
before the 500 but that's not really an
off week to me um so yes we only have
one off week after sonoma
before
that lead would lead into nashville so
you're going to want to go you're going
to be proud of me for this there's a
there's i could race every day in that
that time period between sonoma and
nashville but i'm not i'm i'm gonna take
it off kate and i were going over
schedules yesterday and i was like hey
where do you want to go you know i'm not
gonna race at all uh this month so um
i don't know i want to go
i want to go to like europe you want to
go and i'll just grab my winemaker and
we can go to wine tasting we can go to
italy or france or spain
let's do it i'm down
or maybe amalfi coast
see you've been all you know about these
fancy places and been to a lot of them i
don't i know bahamas in mexico so
you'll have to educate me on on the rest
of the world but um
yeah i want to take advantage of those
whatever it is we could be gone for like
10 days so i want to do something really
cool i mean if i can get you to put salt
and pepper on your eggs and learn how to
eat them and that's probably the last
time i've had eggs was then
so right we're manifesting trips now i
like the direction that we ended up
going with that that's fun because i
have a lot of time for that now yeah
yeah i we will lean on you for sure and
hey if we go to europe feel free because
we need we need your we need your help
we love going going places with danica
oh
all right well good luck this season
even if you win half the races you won
last year uh it'll be still an amazing
year and if you win twice as many well
i i mean it'll be speechless but it
wouldn't shock me either because you're
that good i mean the amount of top fives
how many top fives did you have in 2021
uh i don't know
i i forget i'd have to live
i'm sure a lot
yeah i won 10 so
probably another 10 more
close maybe yeah i think something like
that i don't know yeah
i'm not sure
well good luck right now and remember to
charge your crystals
and and don't forget
we have okay so when you come out to
phoenix for the race
or vegas whatever somewhere in there
we're gonna go crystal shopping
okay
i was too nervous last year when i saw
you
what i said i can't wait till caitlyn
watches this
she's been rolling her eyes oh yeah she
thinks the dumbest thing ever i didn't
want to mess with your flow last night
i'm gonna be honest when i i remember
when you the first time i ever saw you
lay your crystals out on the table
outside of ricky's house i was like what
the heck this girl is lost her mind
but hey it's what it's
it does it's fine you know it's cool
everybody's got their thing
placebo effect you know placebo effect
is a real effect
i think i've heard you definitely talk
about that a few times
it works like 30 of the time sibo effect
okay that's the power of the mind
without even really using the mind now
engage it
and we're going to be on that yacht and
they multicoast my friend
okay
i'm down let's go
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button